[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's talk about volume
control with Google Cast.
When you build for
Google Cast, you
have to understand it's a
really powerful experience.
You're in control of
a big TV on the wall,
and you're in control of a
big powerful sound system.
So it's really important
to follow our UX guideline
principles about
how you do volume.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Now what I'm talking
about is that when
you're controlling
volume on the phone,
the last thing I
want to have to do
is put my phone down
to look for the remote
to control the volume.
If it starts blasting really
loudly, what I need to do
is immediately control
the volume from my phone.
So let's break it down.
First thing you need
to do is make sure
that the buttons on
the phone control
the volume on the Cast device.
Secondly, they should
work on the Lock Screen.
And thirdly, they
should even work
when you're in another app.
Be aware that if another
app is in the foreground,
it may not be possible to
control the volume at a system
level.
So there are limitations
in what you can do when
your app is in the background.
Ideally, your app will provide
onscreen sliders as well as
physical buttons to give
your users options about how
they control the volume.
These might seem
like simple tips,
but it's super
important to ensure
that your user feels in control
of their powerful entertainment
system.
Not only that, but they'll
stick with your app
instead of finding an alternate
that does things properly.
I'm Alex Danilo and I can't
wait to run my 2,000 watt
speakers through your app.
[MUSIC PLAYING]